hey everyone I'm Lana gelareh and
joining me right now is Sam heughan who
you may know from Outlander is Jamie
Fraser hi how you doing good to see you
thank you so much for welcoming me back
to set thank you it's good to have you
here in our another bar actually you
always find you in the bar of course
how are you describing Jamie's journey
in this fourth season Jamie really is
trying to establish a family in a home
for him this season is about home and
providing for those around him and the
ones he loves
and really fighting for that and of
course America is it's not quite fully
formed yet so there's a lot of dangers
there it is a pen like for you
recreating early America in Scotland
yeah there are no fast-food joints so
there's nothing to eat and they drive
alongside of the road so it's it's been
confusing but no it's it's amazing you
we're shooting in Scotland but it's just
been incredible how just perfectly
Scotland doubles for for North Carolina
actually went before we started shooting
I went to North Carolina and and checked
it out and it's just incredible to see
the similarities the forests and the
mountains ranges and yeah I think people
are gonna be pretty shocked when they
find out Jamie wants to start off start
new so he builds Frazier's Ridge can you
talk a little bit about the first time
you saw that set they find this place
that they fall in love with and it's
phrases rich or becomes known as that
and it is you know where they're gonna
make their home this must be the most
beautiful land I've ever seen
and finally Jamie and Claire get to get
something together get to be happy to be
happy for time how would you describe
Claire and Jamie's relationship together
in season four now that they actually
are together exactly you know there has
been a lot of drama over the seasons and
Jamie's always wanted to establish a
home for himself he wants to be the lay
our dealings have an extended family so
yeah so they find this place and it
he does feel like home and we'll call it
phrases rich there's a great love and
affection for this new world so they
start to build their their homestead and
and meet some other characters and
extended family and it's been terrific
and those scenes I think are gonna be
fan favorites I love the fact that Ian
and Jamie always had the greatest
dynamic together and they're kind of
uncle hood he really is a father figure
for Ian at this point you know Jamie has
always looked very fondly on to Jungian
as you said he comes into his own in the
season and the progression or the the
sort of change in young eNOS is
remarkable it becomes a man this season
and you see him find his own identity as
well I'll not stand in your way any
longer there are some steamy scenes
there there are some steamy scenes in my
new homestead yes there may be if you
have to watch obviously to find out
that's all I'm saying
[Music]